[Music]
this episode switches perspectives from
our central trio of charles oliver and
mabel to theodimus john pitched me the
episode as this silent episode entirely
from the point of view of the deaf
character
one of the things we were really adamant
about was this is not just a gimmick the
person driving the episode is a central
emotional component of the overall
season
[Music]
[Music]
i had the great privilege of meeting
james caverley who plays theo early on
in prep and it was great to meet him
because he asked me some great questions
and one of those questions was how will
the deaf audience know the difference
between theo's storyline and the
storyline of the hearing characters
[Music]
it started to inform the way in which i
wanted to
shoot the episode we did a lot of point
of view shots and we were really really
committed to whatever theo sees that's
what we're shooting we're really
grounding it in his subjective point of
view
my favorite scene is the crux of the
episode
where
theo and zoe are on the rooftop this is
the moment that we've been waiting for
the entire series where we get to
finally find out what happened 10 years
ago
[Music]
i just felt stunned by the level of
performance from olivia and james
working with james was so much fun in a
way i've never experienced before we met
on zoom for some rehearsal because i had
realized that i wouldn't know what my
cues were because his lines were also
inside nathan and olivia learned asl for
this and did such a remarkable job
[Music]
it's uh very challenging but doug
coached me through the whole thing
[Music]
and of course james caverley was very
supportive of me trying to speak his
language
[Music]
he's an extraordinary young actor his
ability to do something that was very
difficult and very emotional take after
take after take i was so proud of him it
was just one of those moments where you
get goosebumps and remember how much you
love your job because you're like the
first audience of something
[Music]
as an arab american woman i feel like so
much of my career has been about
representing the underrepresented and to
be able to do that now in the deaf
community i just was so honored
[Music]
i think it opens up a broader world for
what we expect from television i think
the bar is being raised because we're
seeing that this works really really
well
[Music]
[Music]
you